there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
sixteen rules for living with less a
free ebook which you can download right
now at the minimalists com slash
resources enjoy is recycling actually
making a difference I've heard a lot
about how expensive it is to recycle
materials and that most recycled waste
ends up in landfills anyway it seems as
if it is merely perceived as a
responsible decision for the environment
so I'd be curious to see what the data
says I've got an article on exactly this
topic coming out in Wired as soon as I
finish it and then after a little bit
where I look at in particular plastics
recycling which is something that we
have been told is a really important
really valuable thing to do and the
evidence convinces me otherwise the only
way for example that America's post
consumer plastic winds up in the ocean
is if we put it in our recycle bins if
we put it in the trash bin it goes to
landfill and when you hear the word
landfill a lot of people think of a town
dump from the 1940s you know there are
rats everywhere and birds flying
overhead it's this environmental
nightmare that might have been true in
the 1940s modern landfills are very
environmentally stable they are
regulated like crazy as they should be
and they're basically a big old hole in
the ground that is walled off from the
rest of the environment so I really I've
got very little problem with modern
landfills we put our trash in that
landfill landfill fills up you seal it
you put earth on top you build a solar
farm or a playground end of story
I just don't see a bunch of harm there
you put plastic in a recycle bin it
enters this really weird complex global
global supply chain where essentially it
gets turned into a bale of plastics and
very often that bale gets put on a ship
and sent to a low-income country with
very very poor pollution controls and it
is not the case that everything in that
bale winds up getting recycled
great and a terrifying sense documentary
called plastic China that looks at what
actually happens inside the Chinese
recycling industry and you watch these
desperately poor people pick through
oceans of plastic for the stuff that
they can actually turn into pellets and
and recycle profitably and the rest just
kind of blows off into the environment
or gets dumped in an open pit or gets
burned or winds up in the oceans so
depending on how you do the calculation
if there's a wide range I think we
Americans put something between about
seventy thousand and seven hundred
thousand containers worth of our plastic
trash in the ocean via our recycling
efforts over the year this needs to stop
absolutely needs to stop it sounds to me
like like the answer is again it's not a
zero waste lifestyle although I really
applaud the people who who try that out
I know that it's not practical for most
of us and I can't imagine how much work
that is but right right but and so I for
me I've always been a proponent of of
consuming less of the unnecessary thing
so if I have the option of you know
bringing my own bag instead of getting
the plastic bag at the store I'm going
to do that although of course if I'm
just buying a bunch of the canvas bags
that's probably worse on the environment
than having it actual it actually is it
turns out you need to reuse that canvas
that hemp that whatever bag many many
many times like ten thousands yeah the
time so much study you look at yeah
before the environmental impact is lower
for that than it is for just using those
those plastic bags keep in mind the
reason plastic is so cheap is that it
doesn't cost very much the raw materials
don't cost very much and they make the
stuff in gigantic factories so that's
not the case for your hemp bag your
canvas bag even your paper bag which we
chop down trees to make so this this
gets very weird very quickly and it's
counterintuitive especially because
we've had that mantra of reduce reuse
recycle drilled into us for 40 or 50
years
been drilled into me of those three the
one that I still categorically agree
with is yours
it's reduce and just think about your
consumption patterns I'm a I'm less of a
fan of reuse I'm actually I think
recycling probably does more harm than
good overall Wow